so when we recruited speakers I had the
task of recruiting half the speakers for
the Institute and we had a few criteria
one of which was content knowledge we
carved up the ancient world the Middle
East North Africa and the different
topics and we said who is an expert on
this topic let me have a filter it but
as you know not every expert is always a
great communicator a great educator so
let me said okay who's also a good
teacher
and so this got narrower and narrower
and then I put the first talk I not only
had those two criteria I needed someone
to start us off with a bang so this is
quite challenging but I think we have
very strongly succeeded I'm very excited
about our first speaker today for Sir
Kenneth Horrell I'm gonna introduce him
so first Horrell is a professor of
classical and Byzantine history at
Tulane University in New Orleans where
he teaches on a variety of topics Greek
and Roman history Byzantine history
Crusader history one of the reasons we
picked him in particular was he teaches
just about everything in fact he has
recently completed a course who's heard
of the teaching company I see a few
hands
I think it's possible from my own
private research that Professor Carl is
the most widely published teacher of the
teaching company with 11 courses done so
far
and if you've never heard of the
teaching company it's basically a
remarkable service they basically record
professors they call the best college
lecturers in the country they scout out
they look for highly rated teachers they
record courses and 30 minute segments
you can listen to one to drive to work
and presto Carlson just about everything
which means that he's a great person to
think about how the ancient world fits
into the world history more broadly now
who's the world history teacher so I saw
a lot of hands go up to continue
he's also an extraordinary teacher he is
one the student body Teaching Award nine
times which I thought was pretty
remarkable as well as well as baler of
the universities nationwide Award for
great teachers so we have a great
professor amongst us
he's also an archaeological work in
Turkey he's an expert in numismatic
coins he works a lot on his new book
coming out on Rome and her irani info so
he works not just in the greco-roman
world we often think about is sort of
located in the Italian you know the the
peninsula there are the in Greece but
also in Iran and Turkey
and I just wanna plug a few of his
teaching company courses origins of
great ancient civilization barbarian
empires of the steppes Roman the
barbarians great ancient civilizations
of Asia Minor please join me in
welcoming a wonderful first speaker is
in here and then you can clip it right
up here that's how we usually do it okay
I'm a trainable primate I've done this
many times with the teaching company
yeah that out of the way in my pocket
okay well I think Sam Ross for that very
kind introduction it was so kind I don't
even recognize myself from the
description and I hope that I can give
you an introduction to the ancient world
which will be useful to you I will be
here until I guess the seventh I then
have to leave at noon please feel free
to follow up with questions and talk to
me I have not been able to cover all of
the civilizations particularly the later
ones east of the Euphrates as I like to
call them but I'm open to any kind of
questions on the ancient or the medieval
world and if you have concerns about
something like stew sanon in Persia or
ku sean's which I won't cover in this
lecture feel free to bring those up with
me and I'll be able to give you
bibliography and suggestions what I'm
doing today is a orientation of the
ancient world as its traditionally
taught in American colleges and
universities I've taught a course many
years called ancient near-eastern Greece
and I'm not sure how everyone is
familiar with it but what I want to do
is orient you on how to understand the
ancient world and perhaps integrated
into world history or other types of
courses you might be giving so think of
this and myself as a useful resource a
disposable resource which you can make
use of in organizing ancient history
it's a kind of daunting task most of my
colleagues now are quite the modernist
anything before 1900 is
vaguely ancient in their mind and when
they asked me to teach the ancient world
they have very little understanding of
what the amount of time and space is but
to give you an orientation now research
has has really pushed back the Neolithic
period to at least around 9,000 10,000
BC when you get serious domestication of
animals and the most impressive sight
gobekli tepe shows the earliest
monumental architecture and we've often
called that now the a ceramic Neolithic
that is the beginning of farming and
domestication of animals and this occurs
in the Middle East which I prefer to
call the Near East but it's become the
Middle East since 1945 that's another
story and it's actually occurred in the
in the area where my wife was born and
grew up and I often suspect that my wife
has DNA that goes back to these early
farmers and monumental builders it then
moves into the Neolithic period Chateau
huic which means fork Hill and Turkish
one of the best documented early farming
communities calculate thick refers again
to the introduction of copper comes from
the greek call costs and lifts thoughts
together and that represents another
stage and then you go into the Bronze
Age which sees the developments of a
three major river valley civilizations
urban literate civilizations which many
of you may be familiar with I'll talk a
bit about Egypt's umar and Melua or the
indus valley this leads to the
development of a great Bronze Age order
from 1500 to about 1220 BC an imperial
order there's been a good deal of
scholarship on the communication among
the great powers at the time in the Near
East that would include Egypt the Chi
sites of Babylon the Mitanni
especially the Hittite Empire near and
dear to me in Asia Minor and the early
Mycenaean or keying kingdoms of Greece
this represented the pinnacle of
developments going all the way back to
the a ceramic period where increasing
sophistication and agriculture
development of trade development of
literacy and cities are able to sustain
these great imperial orders this order
collapses there's still a lot of
speculation why various explanations why
this order breaks up I'll talk about in
a bit more detail in the substance of
the lecture and this represents a major
break of the Bronze Age and there are
many scholars who study the Bronze Age
or the origins of civilization and then
there's a lot of scholars who study the
post Bronze Age we often call it Iron
Age when iron comes into general use and
alphabetic writing and that is usually
dated somewhere around 1900 BC and that
sees the development of the classical
civilizations in which I was originally
trained that would include Hellenic and
Greek eventually the Roman Empire and
then the breakup of the Roman Empire
which is in a way the summation of these
civilizations in another major break so
you have these two breaks one at the end
of the Bronze Age one in the 5th and 6th
centuries which sees the Roman cultural
order evolved into what is essentially
Western Europe Eastern Europe centered
on the Byzantine Empire in
Constantinople and then an Islamic
civilization which is on the southern
shores of North out of the Metro a nian
North Africa and the eastern provinces
of the Roman world in Iran and so you
get this division of civilizations which
still obtains today the the only major
change in that new order that emerges in
the 7th and 8th century is that Spain
eventually goes back Christian what
becomes turkey goes Islamic and that's a
major change of the 14th and 15th
century which is a little outside the
scope of this talk in looking at the
origins of Bronze Age civilization there
has been exciting work done primarily by
American scholars who are in apologists
and training and a crazy group of people
they are really quite remarkable
scholars who have been excavating in
what is now eastern Turkey they have
pushed back the dates of the
domestication of animals
and plants considerably they have
undermined a very common argument that
would have been made say post-1945 that
there was a Neolithic Revolution that is
the population got to a point where it
had to invent farming or it would starve
and actually that that notion was
pioneered by scholars writing in the 40s
and 50s has essentially been discarded
and what you see is a much more gradual
evolution in experimentation with
animals and as Michael Rosenberg who was
one of the fellows working out there has
demonstrated the first animal probably
domesticated for food was the pig
Michael always loves to point that out
there was articles run in the New York
Times nice Jewish boy determines Pig
first animal on the menu we loves
handing these out and he as well as a
whole group of teams have been working
out here the origins of metallurgy the
movement to the first ceramics and the
most spectacular sight which had been
anticipated that was recovered about
four or five years ago and made it on
the tourist trade is gobekli tepe
which is a stunning site in southeastern
Turkey which is the first monumental
architecture in the world this is the
excavation as it looks several years ago
I have not been back since the
disturbances in southeastern Turkey that
fighting between the Kurds and the
Turkish army and I shudder to think
what's going on in Turkey right now my
my wife is there with her family
visiting and it is a clearly a sanctuary
built by people who had pooled their
labour together to set up these great
monoliths and the reconstruction of it
is it looks eerily similar to Stonehenge
in some ways except it's about anyone
familiar with Stone Age it's well over
6,000 years earlier you have a draw most
running in here a set of monoliths with
marvellous carvings the upper levels and
when you're at the site you can actually
stand up and look in clearly this is for
ceremonies you'd have to ascend in
ladders
to perform whatever is going on and the
site is also with some distance from any
water source as far as we can tell and
so this represents an enormous pooling
of resources by people who are in the
early stages of domesticating animals in
plants and are still largely what we
would call hunter-gatherers there are
several other sites that we suspect had
similar architecture unfortunately one
of them was washed away by the Ataturk
Euphrates dam project other while others
are under underway but this is in
exactly the area where wheat was first
domesticated the week the I corn strand
which is the ancestor of domestic week
in in the world today here are some of
the examples of the carvings that have
come down to us again with flint tools
and it represents the first stage on the
way up in the Middle East
leading to cities the next site is some
four thousand years later and that
evolves to a site known as Chateau Hajek
here it is from an aerial photography
there's two excavations one here the
original excavation in the 1960s done by
the Jimmy Mellaart who is one of the
most talented archaeologists in Turkey
at the time and has often been hailed as
the British equivalent of Schliemann and
that has more to do not only with his
geniuses and archaeologists but some of
his controversial activities afterwards
the new excavations are at this end
being directed by Ian Cotter and
together what they have shown is a site
that has evolved into a permanent
settlement where the balance has shifted
from they're still hunting and gathering
and fishing going on but it has shifted
decidedly towards agriculture as your
prime food resource there's also an
incredible industry going on in making
tools this is a reconstruction of what
the city the villages houses must have
looked like and you've now shifted to
sites with hundreds of residents and
certain specializations of labour
it also shows this is a very
controversial wall painting it also
shows what we think is the first
depiction of a city consciously we there
there's a lot of debate what this
represents this is today in the Museum
of Anatolia civilizations it's a fresco
from one of the houses but it seems to
represent the pattern of cities here
which I showed you in the isometric
reconstruction in the lower level and in
the back is hassan da which is the great
mountain volcanic mountain which has
fertilized the plain
it clearly is also the source of the
Obsidian which is turned into tools and
weapons and traded across the Near East
and this is in a series of transactions
where group a trades with B B then takes
it and trades it to C and they can
travel great distances it doesn't mean
the people who made the tools travel to
the final destination but a series of
transactions move these tools across the
Near East and brought prosperity to this
site it is also an important site
because we have some of our first
indications of religion but much more
evident than what we saw at gobekli tepe
which were animal depictions there are
various representations of the bolt and
hunting scenes some of them may remind
you of the paintings at Lascaux in in
southern France and of course our
earliest depiction of a mother goddess a
small figurine and both figures will be
reinvented and reinterpreted especially
in Asia Minor in Turkey right down to
the Roman period the mother goddess
associated with felines
these look like leopards actually based
on their spots and then a bull figure a
bull who is the vehicle or the symbol of
the sky god Zeus as he would be called
in the Greek tradition
Tesh up in the hurryin hit high
tradition and that religious symbol
persists well into the Roman Empire
from these advances gobekli tepe
is in this area here shuttle Hayek is
here on the Konya plane and Turkey these
settlements see a shift down to the
river valleys both in the Nile and the
Tigris and Euphrates and I believe one
of the speakers may be speaking much
more on Egypt and the origins of
civilization in Northeast Africa but
between about 4,500 and 3,500 BC the
river valleys come under cultivation
that requires an enormous amount of
mobilization and labor on an order that
you had not seen it shuttle hoyuk so
when you're looking at how did we get
cities you start with gobekli tepe
you move to shelter logic and you end up
with the early cities of eric and or in
sumar in lower iraq today and very
quickly a unification of the villages in
Egypt into the first Egyptian kingdom by
the Pharaohs of dynasty one these
civilizations can be broken into these
river valley civilizations into a
chronology I've tried to simplify to
give you an idea of what that chronology
looks like in the Bronze Age by 3500 BC
cities and the beginning of writing
appears in lower Iraq as far as we can
tell that is the earliest writing we
know of anywhere the Sumerians the
people who invent this spoke a language
related to no language today we have no
connection and the only reason we know
of it is the fact that it was later
retained as a religious language and you
have various dictionaries and grammars
in Akkadian a Semitic language related
to Hebrew and Arabic which we can read
and that allows us to break the Sumerian
language and they're still working on it
in some ways the grammars and syntax is
is quite different what it is is it is a
glutinous does anyone know Turkish
binding chance
as a language it's it's a stick together
language where you do everything with
suffixes or prefixes Turkish is that
very very much that way but it's not
related to Turkish and this writing
system then allows for the sum amassing
of resources seize the development of
city-states
that struggle for primacy of lower Iraq
the NCN lugol's and what you want is
control of the irrigation systems and
the trade routes that's what they fight
over and eventually you see the cities
states coalesce into the first
territorial empires the Akkadian under
Sargon lasts about a century a second
one under the Dionysus of you last a
century and the final one well known to
people the amorite Empire Babylon of
Hammurabi these territorial states build
upon the institutions of the city states
they see the emergence of bureaucracies
and royal armies which become essential
to the running of Imperial orders in the
Middle East today and in many ways the
later incarnations of these Imperial
orders going all the way down to the
Ottoman Empire look back to Hammurabi
they are also very much linked to the
association of the ruler with law as a
gift of the gods and the importance of
the ruler providing law for his subjects
so when you look at Mesopotamia you're
you're moving from cities and literacy
to warring States to territorial empires
and the emergence of a Near Eastern
monarchy a Near Eastern monarchy which
ultimately will influence developments
down to today the Babylonian Empire
breaks up and there's a period in the
Late Bronze Age where what is today Iraq
or miss potamia is essentially divided
between foreign rulers the caste sites
and the Mitanni that's a snapshot of
what I teach usually in Mesopotamian
history it very very much dependent on
the irrigation systems
all of this for providing the densities
and populations that could support
cities of now twenty to twenty-five
thousand people as opposed to villages
of maybe five hundred to a thousand it's
a whole different change in order of
magnitude in sumerian myth the god new
nerteaux who is the God of War is also
the god of the canals and irrigation in
the earliest accounts we have of the
rulers of these early city-states they
go by the term NC if they're more
prominent they use the name lugal big
man they will emphasize their irrigation
projects and the bring of fertility to
land as much as conquest in battle
that's how important the system is here
is one of the earliest planning's we
have from this is from the the later
Babylonian period showing a master plan
of canals and irrigation system neatly
organized and regulated and with that
you could collect taxes you could
collect surpluses you could support your
black bureaucracy and army and of course
incredible building programs this is the
rebuilt temple of sin or Nana as he's
known in Sumerian the moon-god of the
third dynasty of or and by the way
during the the Iraq war with Saddam
Hussein this is where he parked his
airplanes in and around this temple
because he knew it wouldn't be bombed it
is a a rebuilding of a much earlier
temple complex going back at least to
3500 BC give you an idea of the
reconstruction of what a city looked
like the product of all of this from the
city of or with its canal systems and
its density of population cities like
this needed trade and they are sustained
by a complex system of trade routes and
in the process of expanding from about
2,000 BC to 1500 BC urban literate
civilization moves out of the river
valleys of lower Iraq to the wider Near
East to northern Iraq to southeastern
ran into Anatolia that is the heartland
of Turkey today the Levant that would
today be represented by Syria by Jordan
by Israel and by Lebanon all of those
areas come under the influence of the
urban elite illiterate civilizations of
lower Mesopotamia the writing systems
here is a example of the full-blown
Kunia form system from Babylon and a
letter from Kota pay which is a merchant
community of Assyrians people from
Mesopotamia in what is now Turkey
bringing writing to that region because
they set up a quorum or trade community
in order to facilitate trade from turkey
from Central Asia Minor to the river
Valley cities of Nineveh and a Shore
that is the cities of northern Iraq if
anyone is familiar with living in river
valleys I'm just curious has anyone from
the New Orleans area or southern
Louisiana its muck man is trying to draw
a division between Earth and water that
doesn't exist I can say that even before
Hurricane Katrina I've having lived
there many years and the there are no
July geologists in New Orleans because
there's no rocks to study and the result
is when you live in river valleys and
you build cities like this the River
Valley gives you an enormous amount of
abundance but it also exacts a very high
toll in death rates eye diseases fevers
so there's a constant need to replenish
the population by bringing in new comers
it also lacks many important items in a
higher level civilization such as metals
wood stone all of this has to be
imported so by the creation of cities in
the river valleys you have generated
long-distance trade which becomes a
significant part of sustaining these
urban civilizations and to record and
understand that trade writing is
invented it's not invented to write
great poetry it's not invented to write
history it's essentially invented to
keep records and the earliest writing
system was exactly
and in time it evolved into the kind of
high literature we associate with
writing today and that was a process
that occurred between 3500 and 2800 BC
and Sumer it's roughly contemporary in
Egypt oh that's a very contentious issue
as to how the hieroglyphs turned into a
writing system it seems to be somewhat
later than sumar and there's a debate
whether it's independent or the idea of
writing was influenced from Sumar I've
come out thinking about it on both sides
of the issue I don't know what I believe
anymore it's it's it's it's it's
difficult to tell because of the nature
of Egyptian archaeology in any case the
writing system also sets a standard
which I always tell my students why
they're learning all this stuff the
Cimmerian set the standard that he who
knows how to write and research runs the
civilization and everyone else does the
grunt work and you should use that with
your students when they're asking why do
I need to learn this well the rules
haven't changed not since the Sumerians
set up literacy is the passport to
advancement it also sees the emergence
of powerful monarchies I give an example
of Sargon the first clunker we know of
and Hammurabi who stands at the end of
those early territorial empires and this
is his great steal a in the Louvre which
are his two hundred and something like
sixty two laws if I remember correctly
which are recorded to act as a system
for royal officials to adjudicate cases
this is the first law code that has come
down to us intact they're clearly
earlier ones that we've found in
fragments but this one is the
culmination of a long legal tradition
and it was written in the spoken
language at the time Akkadian it was not
an academic exercise it clearly was
intended to be used Egypt is the other
River Valley civilization its
agricultural developments and origins of
hieroglyphics go back to about the same
time you see the development of writings
and cities in in lower Mesopotamia the
Egyptians
the ancestors the Egyptians have been in
the Nile Valley for a very long time
probably moving in there as early as
7000 BC as the Sahara started to dry up
and you see evolution to more
sophisticated farming and then Egypt
takes a very different turn from Sumer
Sumer you move from villages to towns to
cities quite rapidly Egypt has a series
of village communities linked by the
Nile some 600 miles in length it has a
sort of homogeneous sense of itself the
population whatever their origins were
thought of themselves as Egyptians as a
single unique race and all of a sudden
in 3100 BC they jumped from villages to
effectively a kingdom the two lands are
united by nama and with that there is
the building of a great capital at
Memphis the ancient equivalent of Cairo
and from that point on the norm in
Egyptian history is unity you have a
kingdom that can move as a single
civilization a way that you never have
in Mesopotamia in Mesopotamia it's a
constant struggle to unite and create
territorial empires you need to build
bureaucracies legal systems armies in
early Egypt you don't have that problem
the Pharaoh is put at the center of the
civilization as a God King and clearly
by dynasty three and the the history of
Egypt is arranged by dynasties by the
old kingdom they are clearly God's
living gods who can consolidate the
various cults and rituals and undertake
the unbelievable building programs of
the pyramids this order breaks up
because of Imperial internal reasons but
Egypt is then reassembled in a Middle
Kingdom which in many ways represents a
a improvement on the ruling of the
Pharaohs who bureaucratic institutions
you get the first imperial expansion
particularly in the northern Sudan and
what is called Nubia and this order is
toppled by an outside invasion the
Hyksos
and while the Hicks sauce bringing into
the Middle Kingdom
it simply galvanizes the Egyptian
populations in the upper or southern
part of Egypt to drive out the Hyksos
and recreate the Imperial Order of Egypt
which then goes out and launches an
incredible period of expansion and
creates an empire in Asia
so when you look at the narrative of
Egyptian history you see a pattern
similar initially to what you had in
Mesopotamia but the creation of this
unified homogeneous civilization which
has a real sense of itself and always
can assimilate Outsiders it too saw the
triumphs in farming
one of the significant points about the
plants and animals in the Nile Valley
they had been brought in by people from
the Middle East at some point very early
cattle sheep barley wheat had probably
been domesticated in what is now
southeastern Turkey and the Levant and
at the time it was easy to cross the
Sinai there's constant movement back and
forth across the Sinai and by 3100 BC
these animals and domesticated plants
had long been established in the Nile
Valley I showed the normal palette to
give you this was a ceremonial symbol
that was mounted on a pole for the first
Pharaoh of Egypt it shows him wearing
the crown of Upper Egypt where it was
from from the south and then after his
triumph wearing the crown of Lower Egypt
and they always thought of the Pharaoh
of the two kingdoms represented by two
goddesses and iconography and a unified
realm
the Pharaohs of course had by the third
dynasty had been so closely associated
with the gods we use the term Pharaoh
which is a Hebrew rendition of he who
dwells in the great house you generally
didn't use the name of the Pharaoh
because it was too sacred he actually
had five different names that you use in
different rituals and as all Egyptians
eventually were conceived to have he had
a spark of life a personality within the
body and this is what the CAW is what
one and join the gods the BA is what
rests in the tomb and for the two to
interact in the Otherworld you must
maintain the BA in the tomb and when you
destroy the BA you essentially destroy
the COFF and that's the whole purpose of
pyramids is to provide the proper royal
burial the Pharaoh was also associated
with the attributes attributes of the
god Ptah the god of wisdom intelligence
authoritative word the pharaoh word the
Pharaoh speaks
law takes place the law is ordered just
as in what little we have of a
creationist of Egypt there's a constant
notion of an eternal order once the gods
conceive and speak of it it comes to be
the same powers our tribute to the
Pharaoh and above all Mart and justice
which becomes one of the great
attributes of Pharaoh's especially in
the Middle Kingdom so this is the
intellectual and religious beliefs
behind the construction of the Great
Pyramids which are one of the great
architectural achievements of the early
of really anywhere on the globe it is a
massive construction these are the
Pyramids of Giza along with additional
complexes and you have to realize that
the pair that the main tomb was part of
a whole complex of subsidiary tombs and
temples and rites that continued to move
informed to the Pharaoh after his death
there was a third River Valley
Civilisation which they're still
studying and that is sometimes called
the Indus Valley Civilisation I like to
call it Melua that was the name
apparently given to it by people from
Mesopotamia who traded with it
archeology is now demonstrated a similar
pattern early origins of urbanism with
villages domestication of animals moving
into high civilization and trade and
some kind of literacy unfortunately is
less than 2000 of these stamped seals
and inscriptions we don't know what
language they spoke and we can't read
the tablets we're in the dark there's
been a number of proposals best guess is
it's somehow related to Dravidian
languages of South India today it peaks
at approximately the time of the middle
Bronze Age contemporary with Middle
Kingdom Old Kingdom Middle Kingdom Egypt
with the Akkadian Empire and the
Sumerian empires it goes into what we
think is a decline and clearly the
civilization was never a single
political unit those of you familiar
with Indian history know that there's
two great river valley systems one is
the Ganges the other is the induce and
very rarely in Indian history have they
been United in a great Imperial order
it's only very late that that unity
really comes to be effective with the
moguls and then the British Raj and the
the suspicion is that this area was this
the civilization was always always
broken up into a series of political
orders and we really can't understand
how did it how did Orban ISM just
decline and fall apart over this long
period and it is in that period that the
ancestors of the people who brought
Sanskrit and we use the term indo-aryan
to describe them migrated into India and
eventually will revive literate urban
civilization it'll be an alphabetic
system it'll be a very different
religious system as far as we can tell
we call it Vedic India or the the
bacha that is the notions of caste and
that will come to define Indian
civilization and its connection with
this earlier urban civilization is still
considerably understood under way in
study I will be glad to talk about that
more individually with people of what my
thoughts are it's it's quite
controversial and again it's complicated
by the fact that we can't read anything
we cannot read that script which would
provide at least some information and
what we have is probably inventories and
ownership seals we don't have continuous
texts and I suspect they existed but
they were written probably on palm paper
has anyone ever seen that I'm just
curious it was you have you in India
it's it's it's very commonly used in
India before the advent of paper under
the moguls and it's incredibly fragile
I've seen it on various okay it doesn't
hold up well particularly in in tropical
climates it just disintegrates my
suspicion is the records were kept on
something like that and that's why they
haven't come down to us it was not in
the illiterate civilization it's just
that the writing hasn't survived here's
an idea of the scope of where what it
covers it covers the induce it now
excavations have shown that Gujarat was
included and particularly the upper
Ganges and the region between the upper
Ganges and the the land of the five
rivers the ad is the great tributaries
of the induce the Punjab and that region
is known as the DOE AAB the do a B this
is the cockpit of Indian civilization
and in the later period it seems to have
broken up here's an example of the
building at one of their major sites
mohenjo-daro and examples of the writing
I spoke of as well as one of the few
statues that have come of apparently a
priest King it clearly breaks up into
differentiated material cultures what
this represents linguistically and
politically we don't know and eventually
it is replaced by a new or
in the early iron age which shifts the
whole balance into the Ganges and the
doe op and that is to be associated with
the arrival of the indo-aryans
and the bringing of the language that
evolves into classic Sanskrit and the
traditions of India we have today
including cashed those are our three
River Valley civilizations in the Near
East I mentioned briefly at the start of
this lecture that it is the first river
valley civilization that seems to have
the greatest influence in extending
urban literate culture this is very true
in the Levant there have been important
excavations at abla and lugar it which
is today in Syria we have variety of
people her Ian's Canaanites Amma writes
the second two are Semitic speakers the
hurryin speak a language that has no
relationship but again because of
grammars and dictionaries were able to
read this and the Guerette fellows are
very important because they begin to
simplify the cuneiform writing system
into a syllabary that is moving from 700
to 800 symbols to down to around 90 to
100 and this is again for record-keeping
Fuger it is on the met rannian it's in
trade with egypt it's on the routes
leading to lower Mesopotamia it's in
contact with Asia Minor a bla is farther
inland this was a major site in the
Bronze Age and one of the first cities
in Syria to attain high literate
civilization it was excavated by the
Italians starting in the 1960s both of
these sites have verified that in the
middle Bronze Age period we see the
extension of literate urban civilization
the other area that's also brought into
this orbit is the Aegean world the
origins of Greek civilization that
includes the Minoan civilization on
Crete which sees the development of a
syllabary and what is important with
Crete the first significant development
of Seabourn Commerce in Minoan Crete is
born
the essentially the Metro a nyan
seaborne trade these are the people who
set some of the basic fundamentals of
later Greek civilization and they
transmit their cultural heritage to
newcomers in the mainland Greek speakers
who are believed to arrive somewhere
between 2000 and 1900 BC and that leads
to development of palaces on the
mainland the creation of a new writing
system and these Greeks sometimes called
Kean's or Mycenaeans take over Minoan
Crete and then begin to expand their
commerce through the Metro a nyan world
and the archaeological evidence shows
these early Greeks active in a wide
circle this is the original trade
cultural zone of Conesus the capital of
Minoan Crete and that is then you can
see the sailing distances here to give
you how easy it is to sail around and
and that becomes the basis for the Metro
Indian trade which rests on dry farming
techniques
unlike the River Valley civilizations in
the Metro a nyan world you cultivate the
olive the vine and grains these are
inter cultivated and you depend on
winter rains to nourish the grains the
grains are then harvested in May and
June depending on conditions it is very
different you don't have the kind of
pooling of Labor in the Indus Valley in
Sumar in Egypt and you get a very very
different pattern of villages and
agriculture that type of farming in
order to sustain the palaces you see in
Bronze Age Greece requires the
development of Seabourn commerce some of
our earliest depictions of ships in the
met reign Ian come from Minoan
civilization this is from Akrotiri on
the island of thira as a Santorini as
what is called today
has anyone ever been there have you it
was a it was a volcano that blew up
around 1550 or 1600 BC
and sank about 3/4 of the island and on
it was a Minoan colony it's it's only
about a sailing little over a day
sailing from Conesus from Crete and the
result was the burial of a Minoan
settlement with all these marvellous
frescoes that show already a great
variety of ships warships commercial
ships that were available to the Minoans
of Crete that gave them the their
so-called thala sokrati or sea power in
the Aegean which was then extended by
the Greeks who came in and took over
this civilization two things should be
kept in mind there are two scripts
linear a linear B the Minoans invented
the writing because they develop cities
and Seabourn commerce by 2100 BC they
have a writing system it's probably a
celebrate and it was probably inspired
by writing systems that you had in the
Levant in Syria that writing system was
then taken over by the newcomers of the
mainland who were Greek speakers that's
called linear B and I don't know how
many of you are familiar with it that
was deciphered back in 1953 by a man
named Michael Ventris a British
cryptologist in the second world war who
assumed that the syllables represented
Greek values substituted in based on the
way he broke German codes in the Second
World War and presto linear B is Greek
it is a form of Greek that eventually
evolved into what we call East Greek or
ionic Greek in the Classical Age and so
the Minoans in effect taught the people
who eventually would be the ancestors of
the classical Greeks writing Seabourn
commerce and that close contact with the
Near East looking at early Bronze Age
civilization in Greece is actually
looking at a adaptation and extension of
civilization of the Near East and in
many ways it's social values its
organization of society wouldn't be that
too different from say Babylon it would
be much smaller it wouldn't be as
impressive but we suspect that the
structures of kings the bureaucracies
the lawyers
support of these monarchies would be
similar the difference was it was built
on Seabourn Commerce and naval power
these are examples of the writings that
have come down to us linear B this is a
stirrup jar that's used to export
perfumed oil and the Minoans are really
pioneered the idea of importing raw
materials metals Cotton's or ivories and
exporting high finished premium goods
that's clearly what's going on in the
trade connections this gives you a of
the extent of the networks by the middle
Bronze Age by 1500 BC Greek trade has
extended all the way to the Western Med
is very very closely linked to what's
going on in the Near East and as I say
there's considerable influence coming in
from Egypt and from the cities of the
Levant these early Greeks are also
clashing with the Hittite Empire we'll
get to in a minute
that organizes the first great state in
Asia Minor
in Asia Minor if anyone has travelled to
the plateau of Turkey today Anatolia as
its called civilization develops much
later with the arrival of the speakers
of languages that lead to classic
hittite and it very much depends on
trade contacts with Mesopotamia I showed
you one of the early Kunia form tablets
from cool tempeh and starting from 1600
BC down to 1200 BC a series of Kings
unites the Anatolian plateau and build
up an imperial order which has got maybe
a third of the population as Egypt and
is able to fight the Egyptian pharaohs
to a standstill it is a remarkable case
of organization this is what the Hittite
Empire looks like at its greatest height
it covers this area largely it is a
collection of vassal Kings and it could
be understood in two ways first it has
taken the civilization of the Near East
and transplanted it and infused it to
create a new urban civilization in Asia
Minor for the first time and second its
political power rested in bringing the
areas of western and southern Asia Minor
under control and then marching these
vassals and allies into the Near East to
conquer the more civilized areas of
Mesopotamia and Syria that random
head-on into the Egyptian Empire this is
an example of the Citadel at hakushi oz
the great capital excavations proved it
was now a ritual City the massive wall
constructions have been reconstructed by
the German team and it is a city of
numerous temples and the way the Hittite
monarch kept power is to relocate all
the cults of this diverse Empire vassal
states within the great capital to shots
today known as Bosco in Turkish or Bosco
leg as they elevated the term and above
all the great chambers at use allah kiya
which are the funerary burials of the
late hittite kings showing all the gods
in procession and the
King in the company of the gods this is
the God shoroma
and it is believed that the Hittite
monarchs had amassed enough power and
wealth within Asia Minor to try to
approximate the kind of power the
Pharaoh in Egypt had they were in
competition with the Egyptian Empire
this is what the political order looks
like by the middle Bronze Age a Hittite
Empire extending its control to the west
to the southeast
an Egyptian Empire that expelled its
invaders and has taken over much of the
Levant and the main clashes are between
the Hittites and the Egyptians and those
clashes probably contribute to the
collapse of the Bronze Age Imperial
water this is just a quick chronology
for later Egypt and this is what most of
your students are familiar with outside
of the pyramids Queen Hatshepsut the
first rule we know of to rule in her own
right a female as pharaoh thutmose the
third often called the Napoleon of the
Near East
my favorite wacky Pharaoh Akhenaten
did he pervert or did he actually
represent the epitome of veronik power a
solar monotheists and of course ramasees
ii noted for his very long reign and his
ability to put his name on everyone's
previous monuments to exalt himself one
of the great PR pharaohs of all time
here's an example of Hatshepsut with
feminine features but here she is
represented as pharaoh with the ritual
beard she ruled as pharaoh that
represented a Chipman of Egyptian
civilization that she had the dynastic
credentials and the bureaucracy and army
behind her to rule effectively as
Pharaoh a testimony to the facilitation
and success of the Egyptian Imperial
Order this Egyptian Imperial Order takes
quite a different change from earlier
orders in Egypt of the middle and old
Kingdom the Pharaoh is represented in
combat frequently here's Tut most the
third smiting the Asiatics at Megiddo it
also sees a religious revolution
by the pharaoh akhenaten who abolished
the cults in year two and worshipped the
Sun as the sole God in a solar
monotheism that represented a veritable
religious revolution and resulted in a
construction of a new capital at the
modern site of tell our mana and the
neglect of the empires it turned out
because while the Pharaoh is busy with
his religious reforms the Hittites are
gobbling up Egyptian Syria the failure
of that monotheistic Creed leads to the
restoration of an effective dynasty 1819
and Rama sees the second who is able to
recover a part of the Empire from the
Hittites and the two Imperial orders
sign a remarkable treaty and 1250 7th BC
it is a treaty that recognizes the
territorial boundaries and if you go to
the UN today you will see a copy of it
in front of the UN building because it
was a regulation representing the
reality that the Hittites controlled
this region the pharaoh of this region
and that the cost of war was such that
it was worthwhile to the two Imperial
orders to come to a diplomatic solution
and essentially create ways of working
out disputes rather than just going to
war it is a remarkable achievement for
the Late Bronze Age there are scholars
who are now working on the kind of
diplomatic correspondence that went on
in the Late Bronze Age and there are
several books that can be recommended on
that topic right now one of the book
that came out recently known as the
brother Kings which I highly recommend
as an introduction this order broke up
again it's still under reconsideration
this brought to an end the first period
of ancient history that is the Bronze
Age
it sees migrations out of the Balkans
that disrupt the Hittite Empire it sees
my cease migrations into the Greek world
that triggers people push it out of the
Greek
world to the shores of the Levant
shattering Egyptian control of the
Levant people's in Libya today also get
involved in this movement to move into
the Nile Valley and what happens is the
great Imperial orders disappear and in
the regions where civilization had been
extended in the middle and late bronze
age in Asia Minor in Greece in the
Levant not only is there a breakdown in
urban civilization there's a loss of
literacy in Egypt and southern
Mesopotamia they lose their empires but
they retain the cities and literacy
their uniform systems hold out or
hieroglyphics there is continuity across
the Bronze Age into the Iron Age but in
all these other areas there's a
disruption and break in continuity and
you can essentially really trace the
changes based on who uses an alphabet
and who doesn't those using alphabetic
systems got the worst of the Bronze Age
collapse those that retain the older
writing systems got through culturally
and that's a simplified way of looking
at what happened to the first period of
ancient history there's a lot of
theories about why it took place one of
them is changes in military technology
that is the great Imperial orders
depended on great chariot armies that
proved very expensive to supplement it
they began to hire different types of
frontier peoples who had superior
fighting skills and weapons examples of
this are shown by the new types of
slashing swords open order tactics that
negated chariot armies and one on one
argument is that and again it's only
part of the explanation in my opinion
it's the same thing that happened with
the Roman Empire you use the frontier
peoples who are a mix of your own
peoples and barbarians to take on
defense and eventually the frontier goes
into business for itself that's clearly
what happens in the Roman Empire in the
5th century AD at least the Western
Empire we suspect that was one of the
events going on in the Bronze Age
another would be if we knew what
the finances were to maintain the
expensive monarchies building ceremonial
cost military cost there's been
speculation on climate change there's
been speculation on demographics it's
still it's still an issue under study
but a number of factors came together
that undermined those early urban
literate civilizations and created a
very new order in the Near East in the
Levant we see the emergence of three new
important peoples Phoenicians ah remains
and Hebrews
these are Semitic speakers Phoenicians
well known for creating the alphabet and
also for conducting the reopening of the
Metro a nian trade routes that had
collapsed and the establishment of
colonies in the western met the arameans
brought in the camel the development of
Caravan trades but above all the Hebrews
emerged as the the two kingdoms of
Israel and Judah which sees the
development of Jewish monotheism and
it's a whole interesting question in
itself how do we go from here OU's to
Jews that is how do you go from a
religion that was associated with an
ethnic group in a specific area to a
religion or monotheism that is detached
from its area and can be worshipped
anywhere this is a breakdown of what
Christians would call the Old Testament
and it really sees a codification of
these traditions in the late I own age
and above all the Babylonian captivity
the capture of the city by King
Nebuchadnezzar and the deportation of
the Jewish literate upper classes to
Babylon who put these traditions
together and stress the monotheistic
worship of yahwah and you move
essentially from the worship of the
temple to the worship of the synagogue
of course they're later restored by
cyrus the great and that sees the
codification and development of Hebrew
texts Judaism is born so those are three
of the new peoples that come out of the
collapse of the Bronze Age the other are
serious Imperial orders the Assyrian
Empire the first and most successful
gets a bad rep they were brutal and
bloodthirsty in many ways
but they're also very successful and
they're the first Imperial Order in the
Near East in over four centuries they
set many of the institutions that allow
you to build later empires that follow
the neo-babylonian the ones that knocked
over Judah and above all the Persian
Empire which is the great summation of
Near Eastern empires by 500 BC all of
the river valleys the induce the Tigris
Euphrates the Nile are in the hands of a
single great king of Persia it is
organized into a series of provinces and
say trapeze that represents one of the
most successful middle-eastern orders
that we've seen today and in many ways
the basis for the later susannah need
Empire and the various Muslim Caliphate
to follow this is the Imperial result of
the breakdown of the bronze age this is
an example from Persepolis of the great
king receiving tribute there was however
another civilization that comes up and
that's Greece the Greek world is divided
into two axes one is the Peloponnesus
here on central Greece that looks west
the other is Athens in the Aegean which
looks north and southeast if you keep
that in mind
you have the dichotomy of Sparta and
Athens right there represented in its
economic and cultural divisions
I'll talk more about the Greek state at
war but you can basically understand the
Greek world from the Bronze Age and the
arrival the first Greek speakers where
it's really part of the Near East it
suffers perhaps the worst of the Dark
Age collapse it realizations in the
so-called archaic period it repels a
Persian invasion that leads the
Classical Age the conquest of Alexander
and then the Hellenistic age this is the
formative period here the archaic age
sees the Greeks become Greeks or
Helene's
the Classical Age brings it to its
epitome the Hellenistic age represents
the extension of Greek civilization to
the Near East
we call it Hellenistic it's the costs in
Greek means like it's Greek like it
represents a fusion of Greek and Near
Eastern traditions into a new
civilization or series of related
civilizations you can see that is broken
up into various dialects and patterns
there was never a United Greek world and
once teaching Greek in Roman history I
always find that with American students
at least Greek history is sometimes a
little difficult you're dealing with the
history of many different cities it's
like trying to understand the history of
Europe but when you're studying Roman
history Americans like it first the
Romans are tacky obnoxious we identify
at least come from New York so identify
with that immediately second is that it
starts out small and sends up being
really big which Americans also like and
that's one way of understanding these
two classical civilizations that came
out of that Bronze Age tradition in the
so-called iron age or the Classical Age
the Greeks also you also must keep in
mind that Greek civilization in the
Classical period was met Iranian it
isn't just the modern kingdom of Greece
and had spread around the Metro a nion
world on all of its shores with the
exception here in North Africa where
Phoenicians had settled carthage and in
the eastern tip of sicily which would
lead to a series of wars between greeks
and Carthage
the civilization also was rooted in a
very different concept of law let me
just well on that for a moment this
comes from demosthenes the whole life of
Athenians whether they dwell in large
state a polis or small one is governed
by the Nate by nature fuzes is the greek
word and by the laws nor moy laws mean
laws passed by the citizens of these
nature is something irregular and
incalculable and peculiar to each
individual but the laws are something
universal definite and the same for all
now nature if it is evil often chooses
wrong and that is why you will find men
of an evil nature committing errors but
the laws desire what is just an
honorable and salutary they seek for it
and when they find it they set it forth
as a general commandment equal and
identical to all the law is that which
all men ought to believe in many
respects but above all because every law
is an invention and gift of the gods
well the same you would find in
Hammurabi's code a tenant of wise men
bit contradictory to the first but the
monsters is a politician not a
philosopher he's trying to win a legal
case with this oration and a correction
of errors voluntary and involuntary very
new interesting concept and a general
covenant of the whole state in
accordance which all men in that state
ought to regulate their lives for there
are two objects men of Athens for which
all laws are framed to deter any man
from doing what is wrong and by
punishing the transgressor to make the
rest better men this is a change Greek
civilization has emerged with civic
traditions that's what marks it
different from its Near Eastern
tradition and it's what sets in motion
the intellectual thoughts of Western
civilization down to today
you can just read the Code of Hammurabi
in in as a juxtaposition in which law is
issued by Hammurabi as a justice
is the gift of the gods it's an
interesting comparison to make you can
draw many others
the result is Greeks do not organize as
monarchies they do not have
bureaucracies and professional armies in
fact they are saved by their poverty
they evolved into a executive branch's
from a very weak King a council and the
so called assembly of citizens who vote
and this leads into different types of
governments of aristocracy oligarchy
tamaak recei and eventually democracy
the city-state is known as a polis which
is more than just a city in an economic
center it is also a political community
by which the Greeks identify themselves
and in many ways we look at Greek
civilization and cultural achievements
and we feel a kinship but in two ways
it's one very profound way actually it's
very distinct citizenship ultimately
remained that of birth you could not
become a citizenship by naturalization
that would be a Roman concept and the
result would be you get the emergence of
Alliance structures the Peloponnesian
League and the Athenian League the
Delian League the Athenian Empire I'll
talk about greater detail and those two
leagues go at it to struggle for the
hegemony of Greece and they cannot
expand their citizenship and the result
is the Greek cities fall under the
control of the Macedonian Kings and the
Macedonian Kings will then take the
resources of Greece in their Kingdom
under the genius of Alexander the Great
and in six years conquer the Persian
Empire and one the most spectacular set
of commands the battles and one of the
greatest commanders of all time and open
to the near East now to Greek
civilization his successors who divided
up the Empire sponsored Greek cities
across the Near East and resulted in the
construction of Hellenic cities here's
an example coming from what is now in
Afghanistan excavated by a french team
and it reverses the relationship of the
greek world-- to the near east up until
Alexander the Greek world is receiving
so much from the Neri
after Alexander the trend is in the
other direction although you have to
stress there's a great deal of
interaction in fusion between the Greeks
and the indigenous populations of the
Near East that brings us to the Greek
world and I have going on a bit too long
about these early civilizations but let
me just quickly orient you on the Roman
world there's two things you need to
know about the Roman Republic first its
constitutional developments it is
extraordinary in that it evolved
concepts beyond the Greek world where
citizenship can be extended you can
assimilate people to the Romans our
Republic is based ultimately on a Roman
month naturalization would make sense to
the Romans it doesn't make sense to the
Greeks and that allowed the Romans to
think of citizenship here's an example
of Rome in Italy at the beginning of the
just before the Romans begin to move
overseas there is Roman territory of
full Romans there are people with Latin
status who have sort of an intermediate
citizenship they are independent but
they speak Latin they're regarded as
kindred people some some people claim
they're the canadiens of the Roman
Republic the other is a various Italian
allies so key and here you have Roman
citizens some without the suffrage
that's a special category Latin allies
Italian allies based on their own
counting this is the military manpower
they are capable of mobilizing in 226 BC
800,000 men a Greek city-state is lucky
if it has 5000 most great empires
fielding armies run 35 40,000 the Romans
can put on the battlefield some 800,000
trained men now they can't do it all the
time the Roman Republic is remarkable it
has all of the civic patriotism we
associate with Greek city-states and we
associate with later Italian city-states
in Italy when it has the burek of the
power of a bureaucratic Near Eastern
monarchy and that is because the Romans
not
any brilliant philosophical conclusion
by the practical need that they needed
to supplement their citizen power were
able to think of handing out citizenship
and alliances and bits and pieces and
eventually assimilating people into the
Roman body politic and that would
ultimately end in a a decree in 212 ad
in the Roman Empire when citizenship is
extended to all free residents of the
Roman world if you spoke Latin wore a
toga and thought Roman you are now Roman
and that becomes a marked feature of
Roman civilization which often makes it
very attractive to Americans to study
the result of this manpower is awesome
the Romans are able to conquer the metro
rain e'en world in the late Republic
this just gives you a sense of
mobilization figures and ends up uniting
the metro Radian world for the first and
only time and it leads to enormous
amount of wealth importation of you can
see the growth in the population of the
city of Rome the development of a slave
Society and South Italy of all these
conquered people's to develop commercial
farming it leads to a breakdown of the
Roman Republic first a series of reforms
attempting to reform the state from 133
to 91 that fail and then finally a
series of civil wars that leads to the
emergence of great commanders known as
Imperator
Marius sulla clumpy Caesar and
ultimately Caesar's heir Octavian and
the creation of a Roman monarchy that
monarchy the Principate however is very
peculiar
it is a monarchy here's the Roman Empire
it's it's height which is standard
public and it is one of the strangest
monarchies on record because the Roman
Emperor is not a king
by law he holds a series of powers that
enables him to get things done to
maintain a professional army on the
frontiers to preside over an economic
boom in the Mediterranean world that
would have no
equal until really the 18th and 19th
century but in the end he was a
magistrate and he had to conduct himself
as a magistrate and the upper classes
that wrote the histories in the
literature that have come down to us for
the first two centuries of the Roman
Empire essentially hated the monarchy
and nostalgically looked back to the
Republic and in a strange way that Civic
ideal was passed from the Roman Empire
to later European civilization my time
is running out and I would like to just
close with this anecdote of what the
Roman Emperor is like there's a story
that's told of the Emperor Marcus
Aurelius any of you have seen the movie
Gladiator he is the good Emperor at the
start
who's the British actor who plays him I
forget Richard plane will come to me
Richard Harris and he has done in by his
evil son come Commodus and the movie
proceeds from there it's all fictional
Marcus Aurelius probably died of natural
causes but his son was an unworthy heir
Marcus Aurelius styled himself as a
philosopher and he very much believed
that the emperor should rule in this
tradition by example not by by by
command that you still paid homage to
those civic traditions at least for the
ruling classes and the story is told of
him riding on a country road in Italy an
Italian peasant woman Flags him down
with a petition Emperor Emperor I have a
petition and Marcus Aurelius says I'm
too busy and she yells back stop being
Emperor and Marcus Aurelius stops gets
off sits under a tree and it is capacity
as a Tribune of the plebeians that is a
magistrate with legislative powers says
citizen what is your complaint and that
is the essence of the late role of the
Roman monarchy and a good point to end
this run down through the ancient world
so